All throughout scripture,
God's people clunked to his promises.
Promises of a king who will come,
a savior who will reign, a redeemer,
who will bring light into the darkness.
True Jesus. God's plan unfolds
from promise to presents.
Good morning church. It is truly a blessing
to be in the presence of our Lord with you this morning.
My name is Chris. I have the honor of serving, of getting
to serve as one of your elders here at Henderson Hills.
If we've not met before, please, please come find me.
I'm gonna stand up here at the
end of the service, come find me.
I'd love to meet you. And if you are new to Henderson Hills
or perhaps you're visiting for the first time, first off,
I just wanna say I'm thrilled
that you are here this morning.
Our hope is that you find community here
and there's a couple of easy ways, uh, to get started there.
One is out in the lobby
after the services, there's an area
out there called new here.
If you go over there after the services,
there'll be some people there that can, um,
give you some resources, uh, introduce themselves
and get you plugged in with Henderson Hills.
The other even easier way to do that is in the back
of your, uh, chairs.
There's a QR code
or it's on, on the bulletin that you received as well.
If you scan that QR code, fill out a little bit of info
of your information and send that to us.
Uh, we will reach out to you
with some information about Henderson Hills
and hopefully get you plugged in here.
Well, today we uh, get
to continue celebrating this Christmas season as we get
to look at the promises that were fulfilled in the coming
of our king Jesus.
We started that last week
and we get to continue this morning.
And I'd like us to begin our time this morning in a
Psalm, Psalm 10.
It was written hundreds of years
before that first Christmas season.
But as I read this psalm, listen to the words here.
The psalmist writes, why? Why?
Oh Lord, do you stand so far away?
Why do you hide yourself in times of trouble
in arrogance, the wicked hotly pursue the poor.
Let them be caught in the schemes that they've devised
for the wicked boasts of the desires of his soul
and the one greedy for gain, curses and renounces the Lord.
In verse 12, he says, arise, oh Lord, oh God.
Lift up your hand and forget not the afflicted.
And then the psalmist ends by saying, oh Lord,
you hear the desire of the afflicted,
you will strengthen their heart
and you will incline your ear to do justice
to the fatherless and the oppressed.
So that man who is of the earth may strike terror.
Know more
Why.
Oh Lord, do you stand so far away?
That's the question that the author
of this psalm asks is he looks around him
and he sees the oppression
and injustices all around him in the world.
And if we look around our world today, it's easy
to echo this question as well.
Why, Lord, do you seem so far away
when we see over 300 students kidnapped from a Catholic
school in Nigeria, when we hear of another mass shooting,
when we see homeless sleeping under a bridge over
by Penn Square Mall, when we experience broken families
and see children left orphaned by absent parents, we ask,
why do you stand so far away?
Lord, across the globe we see rampant
hunger, racism, abuse
and war as we speak.
As we sit here this morning, do you realize
that there are over 28 million human beings
being forced into labor, sold into sex trafficking?
Sadly, this is not a new phenomenon.
You know, generation
after generation, humanity has continued
to carry out injustices of the worst kinds, slavery,
genocide, class systems.
They all point to this human tendency to oppress
and exploit others for our own personal gain.
And the nation of Israel, to whom this psalmist belonged,
was no stranger to oppression and injustice.
Oppression that they experienced from both outside nations
but also from within.
See, Israel was born out of slavery in Egypt,
Israel had been conquered
and led into exile by other nations,
but it was also oppressed
and abused by its own kings, its own elders
and its own religious leaders.
Although they were promised by God to be a great nation,
a nation to whom all the other o other nations
of the world would look to for blessing,
Israel now found itself insignificant on the world stage
under Roman occupation, paying taxes to a Caesar
who declared himself to be God instead of Yahweh.
So for generations, Israel had longed for a savior,
a long awaited promise, Messiah King who had finally
removed their oppression
and reign with actual righteousness and justice.
But yet here they were waiting
and still asking why, oh Lord, do you stand
so far away?
But the Lord was not so far away
on the contrary, as we saw last week,
his presence was astonishingly near the very presence
of the Lord was already here in an insignificant town in
Galilee, in the womb of a young virgin girl.
See, long did lay the world in sin and error pining,
but a thrill of hope had already come and a new
and glorious mourn was already dawning in Israel.
And so I want to pick up this morning
where we left off last week
and see how that was already at work.
So will you turn with me in God's word to Luke chapter one,
and we're gonna pick back up in verse 39.
That's where we ended off last week.
And as you get to Luke one, let's, let's go
to the Lord in prayer this morning.
'cause we do need him. So God, I've I pray, father, I pray
that you'll be with us this morning, spirit,
will you open up our ears to hear your word
and to hear it rightly Jesus, draw our attention to you.
Let us see you for who you are, not for
who we perceive you to be.
But God, let us see you rightly this morning
and let us glorify
and magnify your name as we read your word.
It's in your name we pray. Amen.
So Luke chapter one, starting in verse 39, Luke writes,
in those days, Mary arose
and went with haste into the hill country
to a town in Judah, and she entered the house of Zacharia
and greeted Elizabeth.
So let's, let's stop there
and let's get our bearings for a second.
So why was Mary in such a hurry here to go see Elizabeth?
Well, if you remember back from last week,
Mary has just had her world turned upside down an angel,
a true to life angel, otherworldly spiritual being
who called himself Gabriel, has just appeared to her
and then delivered this bit of news to her.
He says, he said, Hey Mary, you're going to have a son sun,
and this sun is going to be king over Israel.
I mean that in itself is pretty incredible news
to hear from an angel, right?
But then he says, it's not just gonna be any king,
a king whose reign will never end.
And so the bells are probably going off from Mary at this
point, realizing he's talking about the Messiah,
the anointed one who has been promised
to gen promised for generations.
See, Mary's parents
and her grandparents must have talked about the Messiah in
their home all the time, thinking about
how one day a Messiah would come to save them, the rabbis
and the synagogue and Nazareth where Mary Mu
and her family must have gone to every week,
probably talked about the Messiah nearly every
week that they went there.
And yet this angel Gabriel just said that she,
of all the women in Israel's history, was chosen by God
to give birth to that Messiah King.
And more than that, he said that this child
that she would have is going to be God's son, literally
conceived by the Holy Spirit in her womb.
Somehow, even as a virgin, she was going to give birth
to God's own child.
Her head already spinning at this news.
The angel doesn't stop there.
He goes on to inform her
that her much older relative Elizabeth
was also pregnant,
even though she had been barren all her years.
And in her old age, she was gonna have a child.
See God had made the impossible come true for her.
And so Mary, considering all this, believes
that God was going to do this seemingly impossible thing
for her as well.
Just put yourself in Mary's shoes for a second. What?
What an afternoon that must have been for her, right?
How do you even begin to process that?
I can picture her friends coming over later that evening
and maybe they're shooting the breeze talking about,
you know, this great olive oil
that they found at the market that morning.
Or could you believe that traffic jam of goats
that kept us from getting to the well earlier?
That was unbelievable, right?
And then they'd turn to Mary
and they'd be like, so Mary, what's new in your world?
Like what would she even say to them, right?
How could they possibly understand what she's experiencing?
So no wonder we find Mary hurrying off to see Elizabeth
of all the people in the world.
Perhaps she can relate to what she's just experienced.
Now, I don't know if first trimester morning sickness is a
thing when you're carrying the son of God,
but I can't imagine that this 90 mile journey from Galilee
to Judah was easy on a pregnant woman,
but props to Mary, she does it.
That also reminds me
that I think pregnancy is like the only human
superpower we really have.
You women are like terrifyingly tough when you're pregnant.
And yet anyways, Mary makes it to Elizabeth's home.
And when she arrives, let's look at Elizabeth's reaction.
Start starting in verse 41 says,
and when Elizabeth heard the greeting of Mary,
the baby leaped in her womb
and Elizabeth was filled with the Holy Spirit
and she exclaimed with a loud cry.
Blessed are you among women
and blessed is the fruit of your womb.
And why is this granted to me that the mother
of my Lord should come to me for behold,
when the sound of your greeting came to my ears,
the baby in my womb leaped for joy
and blessed is she who believed
that there would be a fulfillment of
what was spoken to her from the Lord.
What a greeting to receive when you walk
into someone's home, right?
When my family gets together, we usually greet each other
with like, Hey, did you see the Cowboys game last week?
Nothing like this.
But you see, when Mary walks into Elizabeth
and Zacharia's home, she's not just gracing them
with her own presence.
Now in her womb, she's carrying the very presence of God
into their home and the presence
of Jesus brings blessing with it.
See, as we get into this Christmas season,
and I realize some of you guys have already been at it since
like August, looking at you, hobby lobby,
I always, I always think it's funny the juxtaposition
of like Halloween direct decorations
and Christmas decorations at the same time.
It's like they're in this battle, but Christmas wins.
So anyways, as we celebrate Christmas, one
of the things I love seeing is all the nativity sets.
My mom always had tons of these in our home growing up.
When we think of Christmas
and we celebrate Christmas, we think of nativity.
We think of the birth of Jesus, we think of the manger
and the star, the angels, the shepherds, the wise men.
We think of Mary and Joseph,
and of course we think of baby Jesus, God's son,
the Savior Christ, finally born, finally come to earth.
But looking here at this passage, I see something that our,
our nativity sets are missing.
Do you notice here that the shepherds were not the first
ones to leap for joy at the coming of the of the Messiah?
No, it says it was. It was John
while still in his own mother's tummy.
He can't contain himself at the near presence of Jesus.
When Mary walks into the room,
and he must have really been jumping in there
because Elizabeth notices this isn't just any other kick
you see before he is even born,
Jesus is already filling the hearts of his people
with overflowing joy.
And it's not just John affected by the presence of Jesus.
Notice Elizabeth's reaction.
Verse 40 tells us,
and Elizabeth was filled with the Holy Spirit
and she exclaimed with a loud cry.
So did you catch that?
This wasn't your typical Oh, sweet Mary, welcome
to our home kind of greeting.
No, she's getting loud. And why is she getting loud
in her home is
because the Holy Spirit is doing a work there.
Notice that John
has already been filled with the Holy Spirit as a baby.
We saw that back in verse 15,
and he's in that womb just jumping.
And Mary, pregnant Mary has raced to visit Elizabeth
after just having the Holy Spirit overshadow her.
Jesus is in Mary's tummy, literally concede with the DNA
of the Holy Spirit and the only other human in this room,
Elizabeth, is filled with the Holy Spirit
and is now screaming at the coming of Jesus.
People of God. There is a time for everything.
There is a time to weep and a time to laugh.
There's a time to mourn and a time to dance.
And you better believe that the presence
of the Messiah is a time to get a little bit rowdy.
Amen in, oh, come on.
I've been to, I've been to Mahjong nights
that are rowdier than that.
We're, we're talking about Jesus here.
He's the Messiah, the anointed one, the root
of Jesse from the line of David.
He's the king of kings, the Lord of Lords,
the alpha and the Omega.
He is the Lord of all creation by him
and for him, all things in heaven and earth exist.
He is the only righteous one, the spotless lamb
and the author of our salvation.
He is the prince of peace, the wonderful counselor,
the mighty God.
He came to earth, he proclaimed freedom to the captives.
He was crucified on a cross, buried in a tomb
and raised to life.
Three days later, he ascended to the Father
where he sits now at the right hand interceding on our
behalf as the great high priest.
And he's coming back one day to redeem all of his creation
and make all things new.
This, this is Jesus
and his presence is worth getting rowdy for.
Right? This
is why Elizabeth got loud
and look at the blessing that flows out of her.
First. She claims that Mary is blessed among women.
Now, millions of women have been blessed
by the Lord to carry a child.
Even Elizabeth herself is experiencing immense blessing
in that way, right?
Right. That moment. And don't get me wrong, the creation
of life inside the mother's womb is a miracle in it itself.
Yet Mary's blessing goes beyond just mere pregnancy.
Elizabeth gives this second blessing
to the child that she's carrying.
See, Elizabeth filled with the Holy Spirit recognizes
that this isn't just any baby that Mary is carrying.
No. Elizabeth in faith
in humility, she exclaims.
Why is this granted to me that the mother
of my Lord should come to me?
Amazing faith that Elizabeth has, that she believes
that the, that the baby
that Mary is carrying is the Messiah king.
She calls him her Lord even though she can't see or touch
or even hold him yet.
So can you imagine what this church would look like,
what our lives would look like if we carried that same
humility in our approach to the king, that we had this
humility in us that says, why is it granted to us
that we could even be in the presence of you, king Jesus?
Our lives would look drastically different.
And then finally, Elizabeth offers a third blessing
again on Mary that she is blessed.
But take note of the reason is not
because she is worthy of blessing for her righteousness or
because of her status in society is not
because she somehow earned this pregnancy
with her meekness or her humility.
No, Elizabeth says that Mary is blessed
because she believed in the promises of God.
So don't miss this critical facet of God's blessing.
It is not something that we earn by doing.
It's something that we receive by believing.
Yes, Mary was blessed among women, but it was
because God chose to work in her to do a great
and marvelous thing.
And Mary in faith believed that it would come to pass.
Now get this 30 years from this moment,
Jesus has grown and he's in his ministry
and he encounters this woman
who delivers a very similar blessing on his mom.
Mary, check this out. It's in chapter 11, verse 27.
And Luke writes, he says, as Jesus said these things,
a woman in the crowd raised her voice
and said to him, blessed is the womb that bore you
and the breasts at which you nursed.
But see Jesus's response to her, he says,
blessed rather are those who hear the word
of God and keep it.
So do you see what Jesus does here?
Is he ignoring or is he discounting the blessing on his mom?
On Mary? No, Jesus loves his mother,
but Jesus is pointing out something here that Mary was one
who heard the word of God, the promises that he made to her,
and she believed and she was blessed.
Listen, my friends, this is my ask of you this morning.
If you hear his word,
if you hear his voice declaring these realities about
who this Jesus is that we worship
and celebrate at Christmas,
and if you hear his promise to be our savior,
to be your savior believe,
believe that he is the Lord, the Messiah, the Son
of God, and the blessing that comes
with God's presence belongs to you,
why would you wait another second
and miss out on that blessing?
So Mary encouraged by the blessing of her dear relative
bursts out and praise of her Lord, the Lord
that she's presently carrying inside of her,
and she exclaims with the most powerful hymns
that we have recorded in scripture.
It's been known for centuries in the church
as the magnifico, which comes from the Latin translation
of the first line of the song, but I don't know Latin.
So we're gonna read this in English together,
and it goes like this.
My soul magnifies the Lord
and my spirit rejoices in God my savior,
for he has looked on the humblest state of his servant.
For behold, from now on,
all generations will call me blessed,
for he who is mighty, has done great things for me.
And holy is his name.
His mercy is for those who fear him
from generation to generation.
He has shown strength with his arm.
He has scattered the proud and the thoughts of their hearts.
He has brought down the mighty from their thrones
and exalted those of humble estate.
He has filled the hungry with good things
and the rich he has sent away empty.
He has helped his servant Israel in remembrance of his mercy
as he spoke to our fathers, to Abraham
and to his offspring forever.
Young Mary, dear mother of our Lord Jesus, how beautiful
and powerful of praise, your words of praise are still
to this day and how rich they are as they speak
of God's fulfilled promises to his people, both
to her individually, but also to all of his people.
This hymn of Mary's, while only a few lines long,
is absolutely just saturated with the Hebrew scriptures.
I wanna draw your attention to this.
So as we look at Mary's hymn, notice
that every single line, every single line
of her hymn pulls directly from the Hebrew scriptures
of the Old Testament, as we would call it,
and not just one reference, there's multiple reference.
It's just saturated with with the word.
See, Mary, even as a young girl, a young teenage girl,
she was well versed in the scripture
and it's obvious that she has stored up God's
word in her heart.
It just flows out
of everything she says in her praise of the Lord.
And she sees the entirety of all the Old Testament as coming
to fruition in whatever God was doing
inside her womb at that very moment.
I mean, let that sink in for a second.
That thousands of years of human history
are all leading up to this very moment
and that very room that she stood in with Elizabeth.
And as she considers the weight of that moment, Mary is
overcome with humility before her Lord.
But as we'll see in her song
and the mercy of God lifts up for lowly.
See, Mary begins her song
by pointing all attention to the Lord.
She says, my soul,
or it could be translated my life, my being the very essence
of who I am, magnifies, enlarges,
makes great of draws attention to the Lord the Messiah.
She's recognizing that all of her being exists to make much
of Jesus and to glorify him.
And she goes on exclaiming that her spirit
rejoices it's abundantly glad because of God, her savior,
and notice that she uses Savior in a very
personal way, my savior.
She says, this young lady knows
that she is in desperate need of being saved
and the one that she's carrying is gonna be
the one that's going to save her.
She continues on in humility,
recognizing her lowly position before God.
She says, for he has looked on the humblest state
of his servant, Mary acknowledges
that there is nothing in her position
or status that makes her desirable
for such an honorable task as this.
Yet God in his might has chosen to make much of her life
through Jesus, and all she can respond with
is just awestruck wonder at her God.
Holy is his name.
She bursts out, he is set
apart, he is other.
There's nothing that can compare to him.
He's in a league of his own.
And then with the rest of her song, Mary illustrates just
how holy, how set apart, how different he is
as she considers her own circumstances.
And then as she thinks
and reflects on how God has shown his power
and his faithfulness throughout all of scripture,
she's enraptured by this fact
that God shows his mercy
and his power through the weaknesses
of his people, not their might.
I love how David Mathis puts this.
He says, Mary celebrates the kind of God he is
different than us, shattering our paradigms
as he shows his strength, not by recruiting the strong,
but by rescuing the weak.
See, when men want to be great,
they surround themselves with a great team.
That's why the Oklahoma City thunder are so great, right?
Yeah, yeah. Hey, you better amen.
Like that when we talk about Jesus too, Joe,
but they're, they're a team
of highly talented individuals surrounding themselves
with other highly talented individuals.
But you see, God doesn't need anyone to be great.
He's great all on his own.
And contrary to our thinking, God shows his greatness
by being with the poor and the lowly.
This God rallies to the weak, not the strong.
See, God's ways are not our ways.
God's kingdom upends the kingdoms of this world.
And see here how Mary demonstrates this.
First she points out his mercy is
for those who fear him.
Notice it's for those who fear him, not those
who impress him or win his respect.
But that's what our conventional wisdom would say.
But to those who had aim to make a name
for themselves instead of God, see what God's position is.
She says He has shown strength with his arm
and he has scattered the proud
and the thoughts of their hearts.
He has brought down the mighty from their thrones.
See, foolish are we when we think that anything
that we can accomplish or acquire
or possess will make us great.
None of it, none of it earns God's mercy.
None of it can remotely compare to his greatness.
Our lives biggest accomplishments are considered just
rubbish in comparison to the surpassing glory
of knowing our king Jesus.
But if our achievements don't impress the
Lord, then what does?
What grabs the attention of the king?
Well, Mary tells us in verse 52, she says,
he has exalted those of humble estate.
He has filled the hungry with good things
and the rich he has sent away empty.
He has helped his servant Israel
and remembrance of his mercy as we as he spoke
to our fathers, to Abraham and his offspring forever.
You see, the king's eyes are on the lowly.
He sees the poor, the humbled, the hungry.
He notices and is drawn to the one who knows just
how needy they are.
He responds to the down chardon
and goes out of his way to look for the outcast.
He's the king of a people who are in need of mercy
because they are hopelessly broken in their own sins.
As we read on in Luke's account of Jesus's life.
It's no coincidence that we find
Jesus preaching this same message at the
beginning of his ministry.
In Luke four, we see Jesus reciting from Isaiah.
He says, the spirit of the Lord is upon me
because he has anointed me
to proclaim good news to the poor.
He has sent me to proclaim liberty to the captives
and recovering of sight to the blind to set at liberty those
who are oppressed, to proclaim the year
of the Lord's favor.
And then he says, today this scripture has been fulfilled.
And your hearing, you see, those are the kind
of people whom this anointed one, this Messiah king desires
to fill his kingdom with.
Those are who this Messiah king who Mary will give birth
to in nine short months has come
to bring unimaginable blessing to.
And that's why Mary can't help but sing
because the blessed can't help
but rejoice in God's presence.
So in light of all of this, I want you to consider
with me this morning, who is blessed among us?
Is that the rich, the powerful,
those highly esteemed in society?
Is it the popular ones?
Are they the blessed ones who are self-sufficient,
having no shortage of friends, social status
or comforts those with the biggest house
or the important job or the high position in the church?
The world might say so,
and if we're honest with ourselves, we might even think so.
But hear what Jesus, the Son of Mary
says about such assumptions.
This is in Luke six.
Jesus says, wo to you who are rich,
for you've received your constellation wo to you
who are full now for you will be hungry,
wo to you who laugh now for going to mourn
and weep wo to you
and all people speak well of you for so their fathers did
to the false prophets.
You see, Jesus grieves for those
who are lulled into ignorance by their pursuit
of worldly success, chasing
after false securities they thank into themselves.
Nothing bad is ever going to happen to us.
Their hope is in themselves
and they're too proud to see God.
The God who gives life and gives it abundantly.
But take note of whom Jesus says are the truly blessed just
before then it says, blessed are you who are poor.
For yours is the kingdom of God.
Blessed are you who are hungry now
for you will be satisfied.
Blessed are you who weep now for you will laugh.
Blessed are you when people hate you
and when they exclude you and revile you
and spur your name as evil on account of the son of man,
rejoice in that day and leap for joy like John
and his mother's tummy.
Leap for joy, for behold, your reward is great in heaven.
For so their fathers did to the prophets, Jesus says,
the poor, the hungry, those who weep,
the excluded, the reviled, the hated
who clinging desperately to Jesus, the son of man.
His kingdom is for them like it was
for the unclean
and rejected leper like it was
for a demon possessed lunatic like it was
for a ragtag group of sinful fishermen.
His kingdom is for a desperately dependent paralytic
and for an immoral woman despised by the religious elites.
His kingdom is for the widow
and for the orphan, his kingdom is
for a rich tax collector, humbled beating his chest,
crying out, God be merciful to me a sinner.
It is for a wandering lost sheep
and a repentant prodigal son, Jesus,
the son of God, the king of kings is the merciful savior
of the blind beggar, the savior of the thief on the cross,
dying next to him of greedy Zacchaeus
of demon tormented.
Mary Magdalene. He's the Savior of John the Baptist,
a strange wilderness dweller
and the Lord of his mother, Elizabeth, an elderly,
shamed, barren woman.
And he's the savior of his own mother, Mary, a young, unwed,
insignificant girl from lowly Nazareth
of whom today we proclaim.
Blessed are you among women
and blessed is the fruit of your womb.
And blessed is she who believed that what God would do all
that he promised to do, she was truly blessed
for in her womb, God himself had finally
come to dwell with man.
So let us too, as we recognize our own lowly
and humble estate
before our king, let's follow Mary's example.
Let's rejoice in Jesus our Savior,
and let's magnify him with every bit of our souls.
To that end, let's pray this morning.
God, if we, we magnify
your name, Lord God, you are great
and worthy of all of our praise.
We rejoice in the salvation
and we love the salvation that you've given to us.
Poor lowly sinners who are deserving of nothing
but your wrath, and yet you love us Anyway,
remind us of how great you are
and how desperately needy we are.
For your grace in your love
and our lives, we glorify you.
King Jesus, magnify your name.
One way that we get to magnify the Lord's.